♪♫♪ [In sottofondo, il motivetto jazz che funge da sigla alla serie "Late Show con Karim Musa"] ♪♫♪
Benvenuti ad un nuovo episodio del "Late Show con Karim Musa"..!
Oggi, vi voglio parlare di una storia d'amore;
una storia fatta di intrighi, di segreti misteriosi e di tradimenti.
Se non fosse che in essa rimangono tutti in vita, oserei definirla "Shakespeare-iana".
Una storia come ne esistono tante, ma che tocca i cuori di tutti noi...
Sto parlando... di Christian De Sica e Massimo Boldi.
Eeeh, vi ho fregati, eh..?
Voi pensavate: "Oh, chissà di chi starà parlando? Così, tutto teso, tutto teso...";
e poi... tac..! Vi parlo di Christian De Sica. Vedete che i video li so fare ancora, mannaggia...
Boldi e De Sica: la coppia che, probabilmente, avrà fatto guadagnare di più nel corso dell'intera storia dell'industria cinematografica italiana.
Per decine di anni, hanno sfornato film su film che hanno fatto guadagnare centinaia di milioni di Euro in tutta Italia.
E proprio per questo... la gente li odia.
Perché tutti siamo stati colpevoli (me compreso) di aver insultato, nel corso degli anni,
le madri di tutti coloro che hanno avuto modo di lavorare nei "cinepanettoni".
Ma la gente (sopratutto su Internet) spesso si dimentica che non è sempre stato così;
ne abbiamo già parlato: da quando è nato Internet, tutti si sentono in dovere di esternare la propria opinione.
E okay.
Solo che, così facendo, mi vengono distrutte le fondamenta delle informazioni di base che ho avuto modo di costruire nell'arco di una vita.
Sopratutto per quanto riguarda gli artisti: per esempio, crescendo tutti amavano Vasco Rossi.... tutti;
ora dai uno sguardo su Internet, e scopri che è odiato.
Tutti quelli che conoscevo, che sentivo per strada, in giro, in televisione adoravano e ascoltavano Ligabue;
adesso tutti lo odiano, qui su Internet.
I Nickelback, PORCA DI UNA PUTTANA!
Io li adoravo: avevo tutti gli album, e cantavo a memoria le loro canzoni!
E, con Internet, ho scoperto... che è una delle band più odiate dal mondo intero; ma perché?!?
E questo, però, accade anche con altri tipi di artisti: per esempio, Boldi e De Sica.
Forse non lo saprete (o vi farà strano saperlo), ma è esistito un bel periodo storico del cinema italiano nel quale Boldi e De Sica erano ovunque.
E venivano ADORATI da chiunque, con delle buone ragioni (secondo me).
Ma, partiamo da un punto ben preciso: secondo me, quel punto risulta essere il film "Yuppies";
il quale, non solo ha dato origine a un nuovo tipo di comicità cinematografica italiana, ma ha anche spedito nel "Olimpo" dei migliori comici italiani....
...(ehm, ehm, circa)...
... personaggi come Christian De Sica, Massimo Boldi, Jerry Calà, ed Ezio Greggio.
E, giustappunto, mica "bau, bau, micio, micio".
Ma sono sicuro che vi starete chiedendo una cosa (sopratutto i più giovani di voi);
vi starete chiedendo: "Ma a quale generazione di Pokémon appartengono, questi yuppies..?"
Argh... Mortacci vostra!
Ve lo spiego subito:
"yuppie" è un termine inglese che stava a rappresentare un certo tipo di gioventù.
Erano chiamati così quegli uomini d'affari di un'età che si aggirava intorno ai trent'anni, legati fortemente all'economia del momento.
Quindi, giravano con addosso vestiti di marca (tutti perfettamente agghindati), con auto di lusso, e frequentavano i locali più belli d'Italia.
In mezzo alla Milano "da bere", e agli anni Ottanta.
E il portavoce e protagonista del fenomeno degli yuppies qui in Italia era proprio...
... l'avvocato Agnelli, che sfoggiava un'immagine ineccepibile: con i suoi vestiti perfetti, e l'immancabile orologio sopra la manica della camicia.
TUTTE le donne volevano stare con loro; TUTTI gli uomini volevano essere come loro.
In una sola parola: O-S-T-E-N-T-A-Z-I-O-N-E.
E, se andiamo a scavare per bene, possiamo scoprire che il fenomeno degli "yuppies" finì proprio quando scoppiò il caso di "Tangentopoli".
Oh, guarda te, che coincidenza!
Ecco: Boldi, De Sica, Greggio e Calà rappresentavano questo tipo di ragazzi yuppies.
Io (quando avevo 16/17 anni, e avevo appena iniziato a girare dei video)
ero uno di quelli che a denti stretti e pugni chiusi andava sempre contro i "cinepanettoni":
"Argh, i 'cinepanettoni' sono MERDA! Argh..";
"Chi ride ai 'cinepanettoni' ha la MERDA nel cervello! Grunt..."
Ma, negli ultimi anni, mi sono cimentato in una sorta di maratona cinematografica,
nella quale sono partito dal film "Yuppies" in poi fino ad arrivare ai giorni nostri, nella quale mi son guardato tutti questi tipi di commedie.
E si può notare perfettamente il punto a partire dal quale finiscono di essere dei film...
... magari di merda, ma con un loro stile... e cominciano a diventare soltanto feccia.
Christian è nato per interpretare quel particolare personaggio lì;
nei suoi film, lui non ha bisogno di rappresentare lo yuppie: lui È uno yuppie.
«Senti... coso: per piacere, 'che me porti un "wiskeyccio"? Muchas grazias! »
Quel tipo di personaggio gli si è calato talmente bene addosso, che non ha MAI smesso di interpretarlo.
In tutti i suoi film, interpreta sempre lo stesso personaggio.
«C'ho un gioco anche al bacino, che praticamente una rischia de rimane' incinta... Ma no, scherzo!»
E non ci posso fare niente: a me, De Sica, fa morire dal ridere.
E questa risulta essere una di quelle informazioni personali di cui tu non puoi fare a meno, ma della quale non puoi far parola con nessuno.
E quindi, nei discorsi, hai bisogno di deviare su questo tema. Dici: "Nooo, a me Christian De Sica ha fatto sempre CAGARE!
CHE MERDA! MORISSE LUI, E LA SUA FAMIGLIA!
CHE SCHIFO, I FILM CHE HA FATTO: HANNO ROVINATO IL CINEMA!".
Però, poi, sai che cosa fai..?
Inizi a sudare... Inizia a starti stretta la camicia...
E, allora, dici: "No, scusate: devo andare in bagno".
Quindi, ti chiudi in bagno a chiave, tiri fuori dalla tasca il cellulare, e inizi a guardare le clip dei film di Christian De Sica perché NON NE PUOI FARE A MENO!
Eeeeh... che ci dobbiamo fare?
Ognuno... ha i suoi "cazzi".
E va be', e Christan De Sica lo abbiamo messo da parte.
...E Boldi?
E Boldi ha cominciato ad interpretare lo stesso, identico personaggio:
anche lui interpretava il ruolo del "cummenda" della Milano "da bere".
E poi... non si sa cosa sia successo.
De Sica è rimasto con il suo personaggio; Boldi, invece, no.
Sapete che cosa è finito per diventare Boldi, negli ultimi 10 anni di partecipazioni filmiche?
È finito col diventare una versione oscena di Fantozzi.
Fateci caso: prendete il Fantozzi dei "tempi d'oro" (con tutta la sua comicità,
ma anche con tutto quel suo sotto-testo triste e tragico della vita italiana di quel periodo storico, e tutta la sua critica sociale);
togliendo tutta quella parte dai toni seri, vi rimane il Fantozzi che si chiudeva le dita nei cassetti
e che emetteva dei versi strani con la bocca quando veniva colpito nei coglioni da qualcosa.
Questo, è il personaggio che ha interpretato Boldi negli ultimi 10 anni.
Santo Iddio!
E risulta essere, secondo me, questo il motivo per il quale De Sica e Boldi nel 2006 si divisero.
Non finì solamente una carriera, ma anche un'amicizia.
E, secondo me, è stato proprio per quel motivo lì: il personaggio di Boldi (rispetto a quello di De Sica)
era finito col diventare talmente simile ad una macchietta, che non poteva più essere "lavato" via.
Però noi, che per anni li abbiamo seguiti e ce li siamo portati nei nostri cuori,
volevamo sapere: come mai vi siete divisi? Cosa è successo, dopo tanti anni di onorata
(meh)
carriera? Cosa cavolo è successo? Qual è stata la scintilla che ha fatto scoppiare tutto quanto?
E, proprio nel 2006 (l'anno della loro rottura), De Sica afferma:
[Karim legge li stralci di intervista posti in sovrimpressione]
Ecco: queste sono parole che fanno male qui, e fanno male anche qui...
E De Sica, con queste affermazioni, ha lasciato i loro fan a stazionare in una "bolla" di dubbi.
Ma, giorni dopo, Boldi rispose a tutto questo mentre era ospite di una trasmissione radiofonica, dicendo:
[Karim legge li stralci di intervista posti in sovrimpressione]
Quante domante... Come? Come è possibile che Christian De Sica debba a Massimo Boldi 300 000€?
E, infatti, De Sica a sua volta rispose subito dicendo:
[Karim legge li stralci di intervista posti in sovrimpressione]
Come puoi dire così?!?
Dopo una carriera e un'amicizia durate decenni... come puoi dire una cosa del genere, Christian?
Finché, qualche giorno fa, non appare...
una lettera.
Una lettera scritta da Boldi, indirizzata a De Sica, riportata sulle pagine del settimanale "Chi?".
(Che più che "Chi?", la domanda dovrebbe essere "Perché?"; Perché Boldi, scrivere una lettera del genere su "Chi?"..?)
Cosa della quale non mi stupisco più di tanto in realtà, eh;
considerando, oltretutto, che qualche settimana fa ho trovato in edicola "La storia di Maria de Filippi" a fumetti,
pubblicata su "TV MIA".
Non solo questo, ma sopratutto... "A Grande Richiesta!"...
E-Eh, ehhhh... e io mi chiedo perché ancora Dio non mi abbia fulminato...
Io... vorrei leggervi la lettera di Boldi indirizzata a De Sica.
Io l'ho già letta; e nonostante sia morto (letteralmente) dalle risate, questa non è... una lettera... bella.
È una lettera tragica, nella quale sono presenti delle informazioni molto personali di Boldi;
cose che sono successe tra lui e De Sica... raccontate su "Chi?".
E, sopratutto, è la lettera riguardante la fine di un'amicizia; ricordatevi questo.
Come avete potuto constatare, ho già abbassato l'intensità delle luci e mi piacerebbe inserire un sottofondo musicale
(che sarebbe potuto essere "La sonata al chiaro di Luna" o "Ave Maria"; invece, vi propongo una chicca);
non so se lo sapevate, ma anni fa Boldi è stato un talentuoso batterista (e, probabilmente, lo è ancora).
Anni e anni fa, lui si esibiva in un gruppo capitanato da Claudio Lippi
(pensa dove ti sto portando con la mente! Lasciamo perdere...)
chiamato la "Pattuglia Azzura";
quindi, in sottofondo alla lettura della lettera, avrete modo di ascoltare il brano "Anima di Gomma" composta ed eseguita dalla "Pattuglia Azzurra".
[l'esecuzione del brano "Anima di Gomma" comincia...]
«Caro Christian, ...»
[Karim legge la parte della lettera posta in sovrimpressione]
I-Io... sto già piangendo.
[Karim continua a leggere la parte della lettera posta in sovrimpressione]
Vorrei ricordarvi che questa Silvia (la moglie di Christian De Sica) è Silvia Verdone, la sorella di Carlo Verdone.
Che sia invischiato anche lui in questo marasma..? Non lo sappiamo.
[Karim continua a leggere la parte della lettera posta in sovrimpressione]
...E, allora, vedi che Boldi sta rosicando..! E, allora, esiste un motivo per il quale si sono separati! Aaaah, ecco...
Per l'amor del Signore, non usi mai più il termine "messaggino";
mi raccomando, perché mi fa sentire molto più giovane e schifoso del previsto. Mi raccomando..!
[Karim continua a leggere la parte della lettera posta in sovrimpressione]
Cioè, io mi immagino De Sica... a "paghetta"...
Mi immagino che, come un ragazzino di 12 anni che non può permettersi una cosa e allora va a pregare la madre, lui si metta a dire:
"Silvia, amore... Ho visto una cosa che starebbe molto bene sul nostro salotto;
dai, ti prego: l'ultimo regalo me lo hai fatto a Natale! Dai, giuro che ci gioco tutti i giorni! Ti prego..!"
Aaaah... Santo cielo...
[Karim continua a leggere la parte della lettera posta in sovrimpressione]
Ecco, signor Boldi: quando capiterà nuovamente questa cosa qui, la raccomando di scattare una foto a chi gliel'ha chiesta questa stronzata,
e me la invii. Perché voglio vedere queste persone in faccia...
[Karim continua a leggere la parte della lettera posta in sovrimpressione]
Dunque; questa lettera (per quanto sia ilare da una parte, e molto tragica dall'altra)
mi ha fatto ricordare di una cosa, della quale io stesso mi lamento spesso e volentieri:
cioè, di voi. Della gente che guarda i video,
che spesso si dimentica che quella che trovate dietro ad uno schermo è una persona.
L'avrete già sentito ripetere da altri mille volte, ma è giusto ricordarlo, ogni tanto:
molto spesso, quello che ci succede intorno (nella nostra vita di tutti i giorni) si riflette poi nella qualità dei video.
E ci si dimentica, spesso, che dietro i poveri Boldi e De Sica che vengono costantemente "bombardati" di insulti e di minacce di morte
da gente che li vorrebbe investire, che li vorrebbe picchiare molto forte sui denti con un martello
(proprio, picchettare ogni singolo dente e staccarglieli dalla bocca), e che vorrebbe strappar loro le lingue con delle cesoie giganti...
... dietro i loro personaggi esistono delle persone.
E questa storia, questa fine di un'amicizia
(che io ho un pochino, bellamente, preso per il culo)
risulta essere comunque qualcosa che va a riflettersi nella vita di entrambi.
E, quindi, io desidererei dire loro una cosa:
Christian e Massimo, mi piacerebbe veramente tanto vedere un ultimo film recitato da voi, insieme.
E questo film, se realizzato come si deve, potrebbe funzionare su più livelli:
potrebbe "riportare indietro nel tempo" i fan che ancora adesso vi apprezzano, e potrebbe anche stupire quelli che invece vi insultano da anni.
Grazie mille! Ci vediamo ad un prossimo video.
[in sottofondo, il brano "Anima di Gomma" dei "Pattuglia Azzurra"]
«Una poesia delicatissima! Non c'ho capito un cazzo; comunque, toccante. Bravo!»